hey guys and welcome to let's play
roller coaster in three this time I'm
recording this early in the morning so I
have no idea how sleepy I will sound
eventually but then again this is tiny
bit of a quiet episode here honestly I
must also say that I've still been
planning to actually record some other
videos but the let's play at the moment
is do so much footage and I've been
streaming so much of this park and even
outside of my streams been working on it
so much that I almost have too much
footage of this that I can't handle and
now my entire hard drive is just
completely full of stuff and that's a
bit of an issue at the moment in any
case in this episode I'm gonna work on
some finishing these facades definitely
that's one thing there was also a
restaurant at some point and some other
stuffs and trees and planters and the
usual kind of stuff actually almost
rounding up this area I must say like
after all this stuff is done I only
really need to still do the queue and of
course the log flume itself which is
something that I'm not really looking
forward to too much so yeah I was just
trying to enjoy building these facades
while I could and because obviously
that's also the thing that I usually
enjoy most now what these facades I
actually had a tiny bit of a discussion
in the comment section amount what sort
of theme this was since I claimed that
this entire area was the Spanish area
but while building these facades and
especially with those different wall
colors it turned out to be more of a
Tuscany looking area which might be
partly because of the fact that I've
actually been in Tuscany and actually
kind of really like the scenery over
there and I just thought that that sort
of look was the best thing to go is with
this facade right here actually with the
restaurants sort of - although that I
must say the restaurant is going to look
a tiny bit more Spanish but yeah the
entire theme of this area I suppose is
still left to well quite some ambiguous
imagination at this point I almost feel
as if the left side as in coming from
the entrance the coming from the main
square this area
on the left side you would have the
Italian part of this area and on the
right side you would have the Spanish
part that's kind of how it looks on the
right side you have the Madrid ich big
well facades really big city sort of
look whereas on the right side you get
the more column for rural facades and
actually must say that in the end I'm
more of a fan of the latter version they
were both things that I haven't really
tried before so in any case I'm really
happy that I actually got it to someone
at work but yeah I think that's mainly
the kind of distribution to other part
guests who don't know anything about
architecture I suppose it'll just be the
Mediterranean or something along those
lines I suppose that you know in the end
it's just the theme park it doesn't have
to be 100% accurate if I go to some
real-life theme parks are probably gonna
find him in accurate stuff too when it
comes to an architecture in any case I
needed a bridge over here well obviously
since you had to cross to the other side
of that on the other side of this the
dark grass is supposed to be the Dutch
theme maybe with a hint of Belgium over
there maybe the left side is going to be
touched and the right side is going to
be Belgium and on the other side of the
train track I will then have a English
section because Britain loves to be an
had not part of mainland Europe so they
won't be part of mainland Europe they'll
be second that they'll be are separated
from the rest of the park by a train so
and there you go well what other thing
wasn't England the first country to have
a full train rail actually don't know it
could have been America too probably no
idea history classes with silver are
never a good idea when I haven't revised
my history in a very long time so let's
not do that
in any case for this bridge over here I
actually tried some new stuff there is
always the good old Bridget SATs which
is honestly quite often used there
aren't even that many custom scenery
sets when it comes to building bridges
but then again I really feel like
building bridges is something that you
should do without the standard cookie
cutter bridge sets
simply because there's so many pieces
that you can build them with and taking
arches that are usually meant for
buildings usually actually works for
bridges as well
I don't know I always find it fun to
just experiment with new pieces and see
what else you can do with them other
than the standard things that you're
supposed to do with them and it's always
it's great to actually see that working
out and see that there are actually some
new stuff that you can try like this
bridge is something I haven't really
tried before with these pieces but I
think in the end it really came out nice
and I still don't even have the lights
and the foliage and small rock work
around that so that should work fine in
the end
in any case over here is where the
little the work on the restaurant
started why am I saying
in any case like like every single
second this restaurant over here is
basically going to be a simple issue
restaurant I think it is somewhat of a
good plan to maybe add at least one
restaurants in each theme you get a
small restaurant that doesn't that can't
even handle too many guests but you can
get one in for each theme which is
obviously good for a couple of reasons
it just means that there's more space to
fill and there's more buildings that you
can actually have a good purpose for
think they look pretty nice to the
pretty fun to build and yeah you just
need restaurants anyway and your guests
need to be able to eat something so I
just kind of see just advantages when it
comes to that that means that this was a
sort of an experimental thing since
basically there there is a somewhat
simple looking look to this entire style
it is a bit of a rural style and you
can't make everything look amazing but
you're spamming tsipras's and pillars I
want to have more empty walls showing
and simple roofs you can't really add
too many details to it so for me the
shape of the restaurant itself is really
important and I really wanted to get
that right and that's why in the end and
this restaurant turned out to not be as
much as it was planning but just trying
out stuff and looking at how it looks
and just kind of looking at the moss and
yeah pretty much a bit of trial and
error when it comes to the shape of the
building they get some point I also
lowered that roof yes but you have
pretty damn high at the moment and just
experimented with some simple balconies
and
like that which I think these stucco
walls beards and why ours concrete walls
or the actual shy guys alpine village
stucco walls are really amazing to sort
of plan your facades with so I just
really like placing those things and
just kind of do that to place things and
remove things until you get this sort of
shape that you're looking for and sort
of shape that looks good and also fills
up this area nicely because at this
point I still also had no idea what I
wanted to do to the rights of this
building that is to the right looking
from the perspective that it currently
is like in front of the building there's
obviously gonna be some tables maybe a
palm tree stuff like that but to the
right of this building really didn't
have any clue whatsoever so it's it's
always a bit hard to actually get a good
building done when you're not really too
aware of what's gonna happen in the
surroundings of the building and yeah
this this little part of the building
right next to this middle square part is
something that I've struggled with for a
while
like whether I wanted it to be in this
shape which was all right but it I just
felt like it ended too soon though it's
too much that like right now the
centerpiece of the buildings really have
you when it comes to like its presence
it's pretty much the largest thing and
it's also the overall shape of the
building and that's something I really
wanted to avoid so I just wanted a much
longer section on the side to pretty
much get some mass out of there as well
so that's what was going to happen there
eventually I don't even know about the
interiors yet like all of this is
exterior work like I don't even have any
interior stuff in any of the restaurants
yet and that is definitely something
that I'm considering to do at some point
in future I think it's it would be
pretty fun if I already have if I
already have my buildings anyway I don't
see really the problem to just try and
get some interiors done to but for now
it's just going to be exterior stuff so
yeah that's pretty much it I'm not
really going to add too much to this
restaurant anyway it's gonna be pretty
simple I always feel like yeah if I
really want to add something else in the
end I can always do that if
actually but it just kind of turns out
that that never happens really like as
soon as I say all right I'll leave this
for now I will come back to that later I
just forget about it most of the time so
either I'll have to be remembered of
that or I have to kind of spot it in my
little rounds of trying to fix some
small things and add some small changes
to stuff that I really wanted to do
because at the moment I'm still not
entirely sure entirely sure about the
the tables in the way that I set up the
chairs and all that and that's also
something to kind of come back to and
then there is of course the fact that
I'm almost addicted and to doing my
parts in that like sort of arts style
ish stuff and so eventually I ended up
also ending that sort of thing
underneath this this roof over here
underneath that extended roof and I know
that sounds very vague but basically I
just got loads of little triangles in
there and placed them and got a little
pattern over there which I'm in the end
not even so sure about how good it looks
but then again I suppose a and tiny bit
of path artwork is always better than
having nothing but I must say actually
that I should watch out with placing too
much of the path artwork that might
become overkill at some point in the
future I don't hope it's really going to
get too bad but um I could honestly if I
if I keep going the way that I'm going
currently but it shouldn't be too much
of a problem honestly and I think it's
all right like the only things that I do
maybe see some problems in are the
things that I really haven't planned yet
mainly the Dutch facades I have no idea
how I'm going to do the Dutch area in
any way yet really need to get some
custom see me for that and not just see
what kind of custom scenery would work
but I am pretty damn sure that I'm gonna
have to actually import some walls as
much as I don't want to do it since
there really aren't too many brick walls
that really go with Dutch basalts really
well let alone brick walls that actually
to have those Dutch for science like the
like the ones in the buildings in
Amsterdam for example that's the sort of
thing that I'm looking for
and there's a couple of other problems
with that as well like I I still need to
kind of decide whether I want to go for
the rural look of the Dutch area like
the little farms with wooden building
and very small houses and windmills and
all that or whether I want to go for the
more sort of cityscape Amsterdam look or
whether I want to go for both and what I
want to get in on the front because
that's that's basically the idea around
the main area and run that one square
we're gonna see all sorts of building
themes but since the Dutch area is a lot
more located to the back of the park I'm
just gonna add one facade on the main
square then add a tiny bit of foliage on
the other side of this building just to
make sure that you don't completely
break the Dutch theme but also so you
don't see any touch buildings in the
middle of the Spanish area since that
would also be a tiny bit awkward and
yeah I hope that that is actually going
to work out in a way and by the way over
here I got these tables in first because
I figured right these are some nice
Victorian tables this is the sort of
stuff that I sort of like to see in
Mediterranean restaurants but again it
just doesn't really work out and also
turned out that these were a lot smaller
than the other tables and chairs in
station gym scorning I never knew that
Capote turns out that these tables and
chairs actually have different sizes so
these chairs don't actually go too well
with these tables that I'm placing over
here anyway but I think I like the
combination they aren't completely the
same the tables don't have the Victorian
look that the chairs have but in the end
it should be alright and this was just a
little detailed placement that's always
something that I really like to do just
get into station gyms random things and
place all sorts of little details so
it's fun to kind of do that
speaking of which I still have to work
on some way to get a like menu billboard
outside of the restaurant slash
restaurants since that would be pretty
fun and I might also want to work maybe
see if there aren't any billboard
banners or flags that I can place
outside buildings because I would really
like to get that in just a touch just to
kind of make the park live a tiny bit
more
I think it's nice and all that but it's
really almost dead and doesn't have too
much of a amazing atmosphere when it
really comes down to the details at the
moment so that's also something to think
about in the future in any case that's
it for this video and you know you guys
know that I'm terrible at outros so I'll
just see you guys later
and wait no wait thanks for watching and